Hello, and welcome to Speaking of Psychology, a podcast produced by the American Psychological Association. I'm your host, Audrey Hamilton. In this episode, I talk with a psychologist about why women, particularly in the U.S., lag behind men in positions of power when research shows, as a whole, women's leadership styles are more effective. So I can be using the perfect leadership style, but unless they are willing to go along with me, I'm not as effective. And so we know also that women are undermined by people not according to this budget authority. From politics to the classroom, the research consistently shows women face psychological barriers on their way to the top.
你好，欢迎收听《心理学对话》，这是一个由美国心理学会制作的播客。我是主持人奥黛丽·汉密尔顿。在本期节目中，我和一位心理学家探讨了为什么女性（尤其是在美国）在权力职位上落后于男性，而研究表明，总的来说，女性的领导风格更有效。因此，我可能使用了完美的领导风格，但除非他们愿意配合我，否则我的效果就会打折扣。我们也知道，女性常常因为人们不赋予她们相应的预算管理权而遭到削弱。从政界到课堂，研究一致表明，女性在通往高层的道路上面临着心理障碍。
Yet they are already overcoming many of these barriers. But they can't do it alone. Alice Egli is a social psychologist at Northwestern University, who has published widely on the psychology of gender. Her book on gender and leadership called Through the Labyrinth, The Truth About How Women Become Leaders, Examines Why Women's Paths to Power Remain Difficult to Traverse, despite a lack of evidence that female leaders are less effective than their male counterparts. Welcome, Dr. Agley. Thank you. I'm glad to be here.
然而，她们已经在克服许多这样的障碍。但她们无法独自做到这一点。爱丽丝·伊格利是西北大学的社会心理学家，她在性别心理学领域发表了大量著作。她关于性别与领导力的书名为《穿过迷宫：女性如何成为领导者的真相》，书中探讨了为什么女性通往权力的道路依然艰难，尽管没有证据表明女性领导者的效率低于男性同行。欢迎你，伊格利博士。谢谢。很高兴来到这里。
There's little doubt that women are underrepresented in the highest levels of business, government, academia. You know, as we are recording this podcast right now, only 21% of women. of U.S. senators, 19% of House members, and 8% of governors are women, and among Fortune 500 CEOs, 5% are women. As a person who studies the psychology of gender and has seen cultures shift toward more egalitarian roles, does this surprise you? Does it continue to surprise you? Progress in some domains is very slow, but first of all, there are many areas in which women have made a lot of progress in leadership.
毫无疑问，女性在商业、政府和学术界的高层中代表性不足。你知道，在我们录制这期播客的时候，只有21%的女性。美国参议员中女性占21%，众议员中占19%，州长中占8%，而在《财富》500强公司CEO中，女性占5%。作为一个研究性别心理学并见证文化向更加平等角色转变的人，这会让你感到惊讶吗？这依然会让你感到惊讶吗？某些领域的进展非常缓慢，但首先，在许多领域，女性在领导力方面取得了很大进展。
And I think sometimes we concentrate too much on the ones that have been so slow, like the Fortune 500 CEOs. It's actually 6% now. And that shows almost no trend over time. But university presidents are 30%. That was practically zero when I was a girl. And CEOs of nonprofits are 52% women. and principals of schools are over 50% women.
而且我认为有时我们过于关注那些进展缓慢的领域，比如《财富》500强公司的CEO。现在实际上是6%。而且这表明随着时间推移几乎没有什么变化。但大学校长中女性占30%。当我还是个小女孩的时候，这几乎是零。非营利组织的CEO中52%是女性，学校校长的女性比例超过50%。
When I was a girl, I never saw a principal or heard of a principal of a school who was a woman, and now it's slightly over half. So there's enormous progress in some domains. The ones that are slowest are those that have the most power and prestige. And in terms of political leadership, the U.S. is enormous. behind other industrialized countries. I don't think most Americans know that because we think, oh, we're in a progressive, wonderful country,
当我还是个小女孩的时候，我从未见过或听说过哪个学校的校长是女性，而现在这一比例略高于一半。因此，某些领域的进展是巨大的。进展最慢的是那些拥有最多权力和声望的领域。而在政治领导力方面，美国远远落后于其他工业化国家。我想大多数美国人并不知道这一点，因为我们认为，哦，我们生活在一个进步的、美好的国家，
and women are doing a lot better, true. But in terms of the representation of women in Parliament, we rank currently 101st in the world, meaning there are 100 nations in the world with parliaments with a greater proportion of women that includes, for instance, Saudi Arabia, we're behind Saudi Arabia and other Middle Eastern countries. So there are multiple reasons why that's so. Sometimes the quotas, etc. But nonetheless, in political leadership, the U.S. is stunningly behind other nations,
女性的表现要好得多，确实如此。但在女性议员的代表性方面，我们目前在全球排名第101位，这意味着世界上有100个国家的议会中女性比例更高，其中包括沙特阿拉伯，我们落后于沙特阿拉伯和其他中东国家。因此，造成这种现象的原因有很多。有时是配额制等原因。尽管如此，在政治领导力方面，美国令人震惊地落后于其他国家，
most nations of the world, or at least half of the nations, the world, are doing better, at least on that statistic. There are multiple reasons. There's a broad cultural problem that I emphasize, which has to do with the way we think about women and the way we think about men and the way we think about leadership. So this is a broad frame within which to understand it. So in terms of gender stereotypes, we tend to think that women are the nicer, kinder sex, you know, more socially skilled, more emotional, intelligence, very good qualities. And then we tend to think about leaders as go-getters, people who take charge and are assertive. Yeah, some social skills, but mainly that they are what we call agentic in terms of the way we think about leaders. And guess what? That's the way
世界上大多数国家，或者至少半数国家，在这一统计数据上都做得更好。原因有很多。我强调的一个广泛的文化问题，这与我们看待女性、男性以及领导力的方式有关。因此，这是一个理解这一现象的广阔框架。就性别刻板印象而言，我们倾向于认为女性是更友善、更温和的性别，你知道，社交能力更强、更有同理心、情商更高，这些都是很好的品质。然后我们倾向于认为领导者是那种进取心强、掌控全局且自信的人。是的，有一些社交技能，但主要是他们具备我们所说的能动性（agentic），这是我们对领导者的看法。你猜怎么着？这就是我们
we think about men as the more gentic sex. So there's more of a cultural match. And there. You know, we think a man can do that, can take charge. And with a woman, well, she's awfully nice, and she's a kind person, but we don't know if she could exert authority. And so women are kind of, you know, behind and have something to prove. So the domains of leadership in which women have made more progress are ones that we think of somewhat less in that way. for instance, a school principal, is he to be the most go-getter type of person? No, it takes a great deal of social skill to be a principal of a school. You have those parents coming in, complaining in the kids and the community.
对男性的看法，认为男性是更具能动性的性别。因此，这在文化上更加契合。你知道，我们认为男性可以做到这一点，能够掌控全局。而对于女性，好吧，她人非常好，也是个善良的人，但我们不知道她是否能行使权威。因此，女性某种程度上处于落后地位，总有需要证明自己的地方。所以，女性取得更多进展的领导力领域，是我们不太会以这种方式看待的领域。例如，学校校长需要成为最具进取心的人吗？不需要，担任学校校长需要极高的社交技能。你会有那些家长前来投诉，处理孩子们和社区的事情。
It demands a lot of skill with people. And so women have made a lot of progress there. Yeah. And it's interesting because most teachers, I think, are women, right? Yes, and teachers are women, which is another communally demanding occupation, particularly at the elementary school. It's overwhelmingly female at the elementary level where they're taking care of children. And so it does then go along with the female qualities.
这需要很高的人际交往技能。因此，女性在那里取得了很大的进展。是的。这很有趣，因为我认为大多数老师都是女性，对吧？是的，老师是女性，这是另一个对社交要求极高的职业，特别是在小学阶段。在小学阶段，由于她们要照顾孩子，绝大多数都是女性。因此，这确实与女性的特质相吻合。
And so we see that in leadership. So particularly agentic roles might be, you know, military general and CEO of a Fortune 500 companies. Yes. And so the areas in which progress is slower tend to be those that are thought to be particularly agentically demanding. But in terms of leadership in general, leadership does take some range of skills. And so women will do better where the agentic theme is not overwhelmingly strong. And it's recognized that a good deal of social people skill is needed. So what is your own research revealed about these types of differences, and men's and women's leadership styles, what does that mean for the organizations they do lead,
我们在领导力中也能看到这一点。因此，特别需要能动性的角色可能是军事将军和《财富》500强公司的CEO。是的。因此，进展较慢的领域往往是那些被认为特别需要能动性的领域。但就整体领导力而言，领导力确实需要广泛的技能。因此，在能动性主题不是压倒性强烈的地方，女性会做得更好。并且人们认识到，这需要大量的社交和人际交往技能。那么，你自己的研究揭示了这些类型的差异，以及男性和女性领导风格的差异是什么？对于他们领导的组织来说，这意味着什么，
for example? I have studied leadership style in terms of meta-analysis because there are just a lot of studies. The first meta-analysis I did in leadership style, what was most robust that women are more participative in their leadership style, more relational, and somewhat less top-down, top-down ordering people about you do this, you do that, would be less common among women. And the more relational participative style was more common, but that's not sort of a bipolar distinction.
例如？我通过元分析研究了领导力风格，因为这类研究非常多。我所做的关于领导力风格的第一项元分析中，最稳健的结论是，女性在领导风格上更具参与性、关系导向更强，自上而下的命令式风格相对较少。自上而下、颐指使气地命令别人“你做这个，你做那个”，在女性中不太常见。而更具关系性和参与性的风格则更为常见，但这并非一种非此即彼的两极化区别。
They're very much overlapping distributions. Then I did another project later on because researchers had started to make new distinctions about leadership style, and they were interested in transformational and transactional leadership, which is still an important theme in leadership research. What's the difference between the two? Well, the transformational leader would lead, in part by inspiration,
它们是非常重叠的分布。后来我做了另一个项目，因为研究人员开始对领导力风格做出新的区分，他们对变革型（transformational）和交易型（transactional）领导力感兴趣，这至今仍是领导力研究中的一个重要主题。这两者有什么区别？嗯，变革型领导者进行领导的部分方式是通过启发，
by epitomizing what's good in the organization and inspiring people to go along with the mission, inspiring them not just to do the best but to go beyond that, you know. to give a lot to the organization. And also then to build good relationships with people, you know, so that they will come along, allow themselves to be inspired, et cetera. Well, the transactional leader would be more of a reward and punishment. So, you know, the raises and the reprimands and the threat of firing. So that would be a transaction.
通过体现组织中的美德并激励人们朝着使命前进，激励他们不仅做到最好，还要超越极限，你知道的，为组织付出巨大努力。同时，还要与人们建立良好的关系，你知道，这样他们才会跟随，允许自己被启发等等。而交易型领导者则更多地依靠奖惩机制。所以，你知道的，加薪、训斥以及解雇的威胁。所以这会是一种交易。
What we found was that women were slightly more transformation. than men, but that that was particularly in the building of good relationships, again, the social piece. And in terms of transactional leadership, there are, it wasn't that women were less transactional, though. There are two subtypes. One is using reward. So you look for what people are doing right, and you say, oh, that's really good, you know, do more of that. And there's the negative approach. You notice what they're doing. wrong and you reprimand them or worse. And so women tended to use more the positive approach, the reward approach relative to men who fell somewhat more into the negative approach.
我们发现，女性比男性略微更具变革性，但这尤其体现在建立良好关系方面，也就是社交层面。而在交易型领导力方面，并不是说女性的交易性较弱，因为这里有两个子类型。一种是使用奖励。也就是你关注人们做得对的地方，然后说：“哦，这真的很好，你知道的，多做点这个。”另一种是消极的方法。你注意到他们做错的地方并训斥他们，甚至更糟。因此，与倾向于更多使用消极方法的男性相比，女性倾向于更多地使用积极的方法，即奖励的方法。
So we know as psychologists that if possible you should use a positive approach, it tends to be more effective because morale is actually improved by that. So it looked on the whole in terms of what leadership researchers know about these styles, which, you know, have been correlated with effectiveness. The women were using somewhat more than men the more effective styles. But these differences are small. But this pattern has been replicated since in other works, so I'm fairly confident of it. What we're saying is women are delivering these slightly more effective behavior.
作为心理学家，我们知道如果可能的话，应该使用积极的方法，它往往更有效，因为士气实际上会因此得到提升。因此，就领导力研究人员对这些与效能相关的风格的了解来看，总体而言，女性使用的更有效风格比男性略多。但这些差异很小。不过这种模式在后来的其他研究中得到了重复验证，所以我对此相当有信心。我们要说的是，女性正在展现这些稍微更有效的行为。
But we also know that women aren't accorded as much authority. So I can be using the perfect leadership style. But unless they are willing to go along with me, I'm not as effective. And so we know also that women are undermined by people not according them as much authority. Yeah, she said that, but hey, if he said that, ooh, maybe I better pay attention. So that is going on too. wouldn't say that just because women are using the more effective behaviors, of course we want to fight stereotypes in general because they categorize people. And so, you know, ideally we would
但我们也知道，女性并没有被赋予同等程度的权威。因此，我可以使用完美的领导风格。但除非他们愿意配合我，否则我的效果就没有那么好。因此，我们也知道，女性常常因为人们不赋予她们同等的权威而遭到削弱。是的，她说了这话，但嘿，如果是他说的，哦，也许我最好注意听一下。所以这种情况也在发生。我们不能仅仅因为女性使用了更有效的行为就认为……当然，我们希望全面反对刻板印象，因为它们将人进行分类。所以，理想情况下我们会，
individuate, and I would just think of your individual qualities, everybody's individual qualities and treat them like that. But we know that that is not the way human cognition works. And once people categorize, then they associate what they observe with. the category. They might see girls playing more with dolls and playing house, and they might just see boys play more with trucks and cars and guns. And so that's there. They've added it by age too. You can, to some extent, use top-down control. I will think about this, you know. But we can't be aware of everything at every moment. Life moves fast. So the fundamental way to change stereotypes is to change what people observe.
进行个性化看待，我只会考虑你的个人品质、每个人的个人品质并这样对待他们。但我们知道，人类的认知方式并非如此。一旦人们进行了分类，他们就会将自己观察到的现象与该类别联系起来。他们可能会看到女孩更多地玩洋娃娃和过家家，而男孩更多地玩卡车、汽车和枪支。所以这种现象是存在的。他们在年龄很小时也加上了这一点。你在某种程度上可以使用自上而下的控制。我会考虑这一点，你知道的。但我们无法在每一刻都意识到所有事情。生活节奏很快。因此，改变刻板印象的根本方法是改变人们观察到的东西。
And then they would need to see equal distribution into occupations. The US, and other countries, occupational structures profoundly segregated. There are many occupations that are nearly 100% one sex or the other. In terms of the sociologist statistics, over half of all, men and women would have to change occupations in order to have, you know,
然后他们需要看到职业中的平等分布。美国和其他国家的职业结构严重隔离。有许多职业几乎100%由某种性别占据。根据社会学家的统计数据，超过一半的男性和女性必须改变职业，才能实现，你知道的，
occupational parity. But we can't get rid of the stereotypes without changing our world. And that's where we should direct a lot of our efforts. And we are. So if I'm, let's say, well, I have a daughter. She's six right now. But let's say if I'm a young woman or I'm a parent of a young woman, let's say he was listening to this and is thinking about what you're saying and saying,
职业上的对等。但如果不改变我们的世界，我们就无法摆脱刻板印象。这就是我们应该将大量努力方向对准的地方。我们确实也在这么做。如果我，比方说，嗯，我有一个女儿。她现在六岁。但假设如果我是一个年轻女性，或者是一个年轻女性的父母，假设他正在听这个节目，并且正在思考你所说的话，然后说，
well, this just sounds kind of hopeless. How can I change the world? right? But what sort of advice would you give to those people who are thinking about how to make the changes in their own lives or, you know, let's say their daughter's life, for instance? Well, first of all, parents are a primary model. Parents don't realize that often they're doing the gender stereotypes. If the woman and mom is doing more of the caring, well, how could they not begin to think that women are nurturing and men are less so? And if he's doing more of the wage-journing, and if she's doing more of the indoor or work and he's doing more of the
“嗯，这听起来有点无望。我怎么能改变世界呢？”对吧？但是你会对那些思考如何在自己的生活或比方说女儿的生活中做出改变的人们提出什么建议呢？首先，父母是最初的榜样。父母往往没有意识到他们在身体力行地表现性别刻板印象。如果女性和妈妈承担了更多的照顾工作，好吧，他们怎么能不开始认为女性富有养育精神而男性则不然呢？如果他赚取更多的薪水，如果她做更多室内的活而他做更多，
thing-oriented, he's fixing things and mowing the lawn. How can they not get the idea that men are better at mechanical things and whatever? And so the first thing parents, if they want to get rid of gender-stay-type, should do is stop enacting them. Please don't enact them, then, which is a tall order for a lot of people. Then they go to elementary school, and the teachers are overwhelmingly female. And now the principal of the school was often female. So it's good to expose if you're interested in, you know, progressively eliminating stereotypes or lessening them to give children experience with the alternative. And then talk to them.
偏向物体的活，比如修理东西和修剪草坪。他们怎么能不产生一种想法，即男性更擅长机械类的事情等等呢？因此，如果父母想要摆脱性别刻板印象，首先要做的是停止表现出这些刻板印象。请不要再表现出这些刻板印象了，这对很多人来说要求很高。然后孩子们去上小学，老师绝大多数是女性。现在学校的校长也经常是女性。所以，如果你有兴趣逐步消除刻板印象或减轻它们，让孩子们接触替代方案是很好的。然后与他们对话。
And you know a lot of parents say, girls can do anything. That's kind of empty. It's not too bad, maybe. Girls can do anything. and then they look at their world and they're getting different information associational. They're just taken in this other information
你知道，很多父母说，女孩无所不能。这有点空洞。可能也不算太坏吧。女孩无所不能，然后他们看着自己的世界，通过关联不断获得不同的信息。他们只是不断接收这些关于男人和女人在做什么的其他信息，
all the time about what the men and women are doing. But we can look at areas where it's very important that women make progress as in political power and we can concentrate on the women in the Senate, et cetera, and direct girls to them as role models. Yeah, because they are there and they're not in tiny numbers anymore. Okay, well, Dr. Eggley, thank you so much for joining us. It's been a pleasure.
全天候都在发生。但我们可以关注女性必须取得重要进展的领域，比如政治权力，我们可以关注参议院等机构中的女性，并将女孩引导她们作为榜样。是的，因为她们就在那里，而且数量已经不再微不足道了。好的，伊格利博士，非常感谢你加入我们。这真是太愉快了。
It's very nice to talk to you. Thank you for inviting me. Thanks for listening to our podcast. Make sure you check out our other episodes of Speaking of Psychology, and please subscribe if you haven't already. We are a proud member of the APA Podcast Network, which includes other great podcasts. Please check out APA Journal's dialogue if you want to hear about the latest and most exciting psychology research. And if you're interested in the practice of psychology, you can listen to progress notes. Topics include how health care policy and social media affect practicing
和你交谈非常愉快。谢谢你邀请我。感谢收听我们的播客。请务必查看我们《心理学对话》的其他期节目，如果还没有订阅，请订阅。我们是APA播客网络的骄傲成员，其中包含许多其他优秀的播客。如果你想了解最新、最激动人心的心理学研究，请查看APA期刊的对话（dialogue）。如果你对心理学实践感兴趣，你可以收听进展记录（progress notes）。主题包括医疗保健政策和社交媒体如何影响执业，
psychologists. You can find those podcasts on iTunes, Stitcher, or wherever you get your podcasts. You can also go to our website, speakingofpsychology.org, to listen to even more episodes and gather more resources on the topics we discussed. Thanks for joining us. I'm Audrey Hamilton with the American Psychological Association, and this is is Speaking of Psychology. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
心理学家。你可以在iTunes、Stitcher或你获取播客的任何地方找到这些播客。你也可以访问我们的网站speakingofpsychology.org，收听更多剧集，并收集有关我们讨论话题的更多资源。感谢您的加入。我是美国心理学会的奥黛丽·汉密尔顿，这里是《心理学对话》。本期节目暂无评论。点击文稿中的任何句子即可发表评论。